okay good morning um so last class we
talked about the central Paradox in
Christianity what Jesus
believes is different from what
Christianity teaches us about Jesus okay
so let's go over let's review uh what
Jesus believes teaches what Christianity
teaches us about Jesus okay so
Jesus um remember that Jesus is one of
are great spiritual leaders and Geniuses
like the
Buddha um and there's a three Tire
approach to his religion or
philosophy there's an inner approach
which is a secret teachings his secret
understanding of the world there's an
inner Lear which is what he teaches his
disciples and then there's a public leer
which is what he tells other people in
public in the public Lear we know very
well he believes in generosity in
Mercy um in focusing on um being a good
and kind
person in the inner leer we also know
very well
he demands that the people follow him
give up all worldly possessions and
Pursuits
if you're rich if you want to follow him
then you must abandon all your
wealth and he demands
self-sacrifice uh from all his Apostles
okay and then there's a secret lay which
is the philosophy that underpins all
these religious
teachings and the secret is that this
world we live in is
false and what's really true is the
Divine spark within us that allows us to
connect to the true reality of the monad
or the one okay the world that we live
in is being controlled by a monster and
that's why you should not hate the rich
you should pity the rich because the
rich are pursuing what is false and in
the pursuit of what is false it is it is
causing them to feel
anger um and self-hatred
so Jesus has this great metaphor and
what he says is that the person of
wealth is like drinking salt
water okay the more you drink the more
thirsty you become and you feel it's
because you have not drunk enough so you
drink more and more salt water and
eventually you will poison
yourself right so that's how he feels
about the preserv of wealth it will it
is poisonous it will only lead to your
ultimate demise and that's why it's
important to focus instead on our
Humanity on our connection with others
that's why it's important to be
compassionate okay and you you should be
most be compassionate towards the rich
because to the ones who are most guided
who the ones who are most misguided and
deluded okay so that's the Jesus and
again his teachings are no different
from say Buddhist teachings or Hindu
teachings or Dum teachings okay so all
these major religions are aligned in
this
belief but then you have the Bible the
Jesus of the Bible and the Jesus of the
Bible is portrayed very differently
right in the Bible Jesus is a Son of
God and there's a conflict between God
and Humanity remember we humans
committed the original sin we disobeyed
him and ate from the fruit of the tree
of knowledge and good and evil and
therefore God banished us from Paradise
and ever since we've been living in
misery God expects us to acknowledge our
failings and ask for forgiveness but
because we are
ignorant um and misguided and sinful we
refuse to
apologize therefore Jesus has to return
has to come to Earth and sacrifice
himself in the
crucification has to crucify himself in
order to atone for our
sins and to
wash us of all our past sins so that we
we can begin a new okay and after he has
completed the sacrifice he has become
resurrected and he now ascends to heaven
and he prepares for the day when he will
return and destroy all evil and build an
eternal Paradise on Earth and this is
what is known as the second
coming
okay and this is an
extremely powerful story but it's also
very
complicated and in many ways
contradictory okay so if Jesus is a Son
of
God then what is God's role in this and
how does a Son of God a god actually die
on
Earth and why does he have to die first
before he can return again okay so there
are a lot of contradictions in this
story that you don't have in the first
Jesus
teachings all right so the question I
want to ask today is how did we get from
here okay Jesus is teaching us about the
kingdom of God that the kingdom of God
is within us and and accessible to all
who are willing to do good to this idea
which demands that we believe that Jesus
is a Son of God who came to sacrifice
himself to redeem us from our
sins and he will eventually return to
bring Eternal Paradise to Earth all
right these are two very different
worldviews so how do we we get from uh
here to here okay so a lot the clue lies
in the Bible and the story of Jesus in
the Bible so what's interesting about
the Jesus story
is Jesus gets into trouble when he goes
into
Jerusalem before he was in the provinces
and he was building a large following he
was healing people he was
spreading um the kingdom of God message
and he was very popular
and he was very safe but then he got he
he went to Jerusalem and he ran a fowl
of the religious Elite in Jerusalem the
high
priest and eventually they rallied the
Jewish people against Jesus and they
persecuted him okay and eventually Jesus
was betrayed by name named Judas es
scariot one of his
followers and the Jews brought Jesus
before Pontius Pilate the Roman governor
of Judea and at first ponus pilot
refused to punish him but the Jews
insisted and so Pon pilot had to
eventually crucify Jesus in order to
satisfy the will of the Jewish people
okay now this story is constructed in a
way that's very very
clever in history who was also
persecuted by his own people which caus
his death you guys
remember which truth
teller exactly okay Socrates right so
this story reminds us of Socrates right
the persecution of a truth teller that's
Socrates right that Rems of Socrates now
let's let me ask you another question
who
else was
betrayed by his own
followers SU
right you see how clever this is the two
most famous individuals in world history
at this point Socrates and julus Caesar
are brought into the story of Jesus so
that it conflates all three together
Jesus is Socrates is Julius
Caesar all right that's very very clever
and you can only do this you have have a
very nuanced understanding of Greek
history Roman Min history and the Jewish
Bible the Hebrew Bible
right and in fact at at this time there
are individuals who possess all three
sets of knowledge and they are
called
hellenized
Jews in the Roman Empire right if you
are a heniz Jew meaning you grew up with
a great education and your the ran
Empire you have access to all three
major sets of knowledge the Hebrew Bible
Greek philosophy and Roman
history okay and the major individual in
the Bible who is a heliz Jew in the
Roman Empire is named Paul and he is
credited with most of the writing of the
New Testament about a third of the New
Testament which is the Christian Bible
either it's written by Paul or it's
about Paul
so that's why we believe that not Jesus
but Paul is the real founder of
Christianity okay Christianity again is
not by Jesus it's not a religion by
Jesus Jesus it's a religion about Jesus
and there's a
difference okay now let's talk about the
life in Times of Paul because it's a
very interesting story okay and um again
everything I'm telling you comes from
the Bible a book called Acts of the
Apostles which is about what happens
after Jesus
dies
okay so after Jesus dies his brother
James the just becomes leader of his
movement okay and they're often called
the poor
in uh but they're all called the poor
why because they're focused on um a life
that denies worldly Goods okay they
believe this mature reality we live in
it's evil and we have to focus on the
spiritual life and that's why they they
demand poverty okay that's that's why
they themselves are poor and that the
man everyone who believes in them are
also poor and uh the word for them it's
called
ebionites and this is important because
the imites will eventually leave
Jerusalem where they are now and go to
Arabia where they will help found the um
religion of Islam okay so I I want you
guys to keep this in mind okay so James
a Jud and his followers they're in
Jerusalem and what this tells us
is if they're in Jerusalem and they're
not from Jerusalem then they are being
protected and honored by the Jewish
Elite okay and this again is evidence
that it was not the Jews who killed
Jesus it was the Romans who killed Jesus
because if the Jews killed Jesus and all
his followers would have to leave
Jerusalem right but after his death
they're all in Jerusalem basically okay
so this is a major contradiction in the
Bible let's talk about Paul who who is
Paul we actually know very little about
the early life of Paul we know that he's
from a place called Tarsus which is part
of the Jewish diaspora okay he himself
is Jewish he's a Roman citizen and
that's pretty rare for a Jewish person
and you only get citizenship by doing
three things the first thing is you're
born of citizens which is probably the
case with Paul okay he tells us in the
Bible I'm born a Roman citizen therefore
my parents are citizens which means his
parents were were very wealthy and part
of the Roman Elite okay second thing you
the second way you get CIP is by um
being a soldier for 20 years and the
Third Way is through service to the
emperor okay the emperor honors you uh
with with citizenship if you have shown
devotion and service okay so it's very
hard to be a Roman citizen but Paul is a
Roman
citizen um and as a Roman citizen he
grew up secular he grew up learning
Greek rhetoric he learned Socrates Plato
Homer all that okay for whatever reason
he converted and becomes a
Pharisee okay remember Pharisees are
Jewish priests who eventually will
become
rabbis and as a Pharisee he's very
fanatical we know that if you convert
you actually you actually become very
fanatical okay and as a Pharisee he was
tasked with destroying the Jesus
movement and that kind of makes no sense
because we just said that if James ad
just and the followers of Jesus are in
Jerusalem that means they are being
protected and honored by the Pharisees
right so this is actually major
contradiction that no one has actually
explained to us okay but you'll see a
lot of these contradictions in the Bible
okay anyway the story continues here's a
Pharisee and he's fanatical about
destroying the Jesus movement because it
is heresy it is um uh Jesus thinks of
himself as a messiah and he's not okay
um eventually Paul decides to go to
Damascus to destroy the Jesus movement
in in Damascus but on the road
there he sees the light okay he sees the
light and it's Jesus talking to him
saying Paul stop persecuting me and my
people and then Paul at this point has
something called the Damascus moment
okay Damas the Damascus moment moment is
a very famous metaphor in English it
means to see the light and to change
your opinion okay and to convert into
the true belief and at this point Paul
becomes a fanatical follower of Jesus
even though he's never met
Jesus and he's never met the followers
of Jesus this is extremely weird okay
but he becomes a fanatical follower of
Jesus and he decides he's going to
spread the message of Jesus to everyone
okay and the way you do that is you just
go to synagogues and tell Jews that
Jesus is the
Messiah okay and eventually he will
begin to build the structure and the
organization of Christianity right now
they're not called Christians they're
still Jews and Jesus and his followers
are considered a branch of um Judaism
okay but there's some major differences
the first major difference
is Paul believes that Jesus is the
Messiah and what's really important is
he teaches us that through faith in
Jesus you will achieve
salvation this is very different from
what Jesus himself taught it is through
good works that you achieve F salvation
but Paul teaches us no it is Bel in in
Jesus as a
savior that will offer you salvation the
good works don't matter it's the belief
the faith in Jesus that matters okay
that's the first
thing second thing that s Paul is he's
focused on
um organization and
structure okay Jesus and his followers
were very egalitarian they didn't
believe in organization they didn't
believe in hierarchy they didn't believe
in structure but Paul insists only if
you have hierarchy and organization and
structure will you have the ability to
fully promote Jesus's message to the
people okay so he's building churches
around um the Roman
Empire for Paul What mattered first and
foremost was to convert as many people
as possible because believe in Jesus
meant salvation so we have a duty to
save as many people as
possible
okay so it's important to make
compromises for example circum
circumcision so there were many in the
Jewish diaspora around the Roman Empire
who W circumcised why because the
fathers were Greek and the mothers were
Jewish and Paul felt it was very
important to bring these people into the
religion and so he basically said you
know
what if you're not if you're 20 years
old and you're not circumcised don't
worry about it what the law doesn't
matter what matters is your faith in
Jesus okay so these are the three
radical changes that Paul makes to the
religion that's being um developed
around Jesus okay and as you can imagine
this is pissing off Jewish people
especially back in j Jem so James the
just hears about this from all his
Jewish friends and say this is Guy Paul
gr around the Roman Empire and teaching
everyone that it's not important to
follow Jewish law and Customs it's not
important to be Jewish what's important
is to believe in
Jesus and so James the Jud and Paul
start to have a major
argument okay James just is is running
Paul and says Paul what's going on why
are you telling people you don't have to
follow Jewish law and Paul writes back
and
says what matters is not the letter of
the law what matters is the spirit of
the law if Jesus has come and he's the
Savior then believing in him is what
matters and we need to get as many
people to believe in Jesus as possible
okay so for example Gentiles non-jews
want to believe in Jesus but they 20
they 30 to 40 how can they circumcise
themselves
I'm just trying to open up the religion
I'm the Apostle to the Gentiles okay so
Paul names himself Apostle to the
Gentiles the non-jews I am liberating
this religion for all I bringing this
religion to everyone Greek and Jew alike
Greek Roman and Jew
alike all
right eventually this conflict becomes
so bitter that James Su just spreads
rumors about Paul and many of Paul's
churches now start to abandon him okay
because remember James J is Jesus's
brother okay so there's an authority
it's James the just not Paul and Paul
becomes very angry Paul tries many many
um tricks for example he he tries to
bribe James a just by offering him money
okay he also writes letters complaining
about James a just and saying well just
because you're Jesus brother doesn't
mean you know what he actually says
because Jesus talk to me man Jesus came
to me in a vision therefore I'm the one
who really understands
Jesus all right
eventually Paul decides you know what
this conflict is so bad everyone's
leaving me that I have to go to
Jerusalem and sort things out with James
okay so he goes to Jerusalem and he
meets with James and at first the
meaning goes well but then in
Jerusalem the people who don't like Paul
recognize him and they start to mob him
okay they want to kill this guy and
what's really interesting about how this
is written is it's very similar to the
Jesus story where Jesus is being uh
mobed by by by Jews okay and at this
point okay Paul is about to be ripped
apart by the Jewish mom but then Roman
soldiers come and save him and Paul does
something that's different from Jesus
Paul tells soldiers I I am a Roman
citizen and the soldiers are like oh wow
okay then we must protect you we must
ensure that you get fair
treatment okay and so Paul is brought to
the Jew the Roman governor and the Roman
Governor um doesn't
believe that Paul has broken any laws
but there's Jewish mob out there who
want to kill him okay so now Paul says
to the governor let me talk to the Roman
Emperor I will make my case before the
Roman Emperor and the governor is like
well then I have no choice I no longer
have the authority to judge you myself
you as a Roman citizen have the right to
talk to the Roman Emperor so therefore I
will send Soldiers with you to Rome to
be judged by the Roman Emperor himself
okay and so if you actually read the
Bible these two stories between Jesus
and Paul you will see how how many
parallels and similarities there are
okay but the difference is this the
difference is Paul is a Roman citizen
Jesus is not therefore Jesus was
killed because he was not a Roman
citizen okay does that make sense if
Jesus were a Roman citizen he could
preach all he wants okay he could say
whatever he wants but he wasn't and
therefore he was
killed so then Paul goes back to Rome
and this is how the Acts of the Apostles
ends okay let's read it together because
the way it is written is extremely
fascinating okay when we come into Rome
Paul was allowed to live by himself with
a soldier who was guarding
him this makes no sense Paul is a
criminal the Jews are accusing Paul of
violing their laws Paul has returned to
Rome to be judged by the Roman Emperor
but this is what this is what the Bible
says Paul was allowed to live by himself
and he was being guarded by a soldier
who was protecting
him that's a contradiction what's going
on here okay but then it gets more
interesting next paragraph three days
later he called together the local
leaders of the
Jews
what this makes no sense the Jews
consider him a criminal yet he has the
power and authority
to call all the major Jewish local
leaders of Rome into his house for a
meeting who gave him this
power from the perspective of Jews he is
a criminal he's asking people to break
the laws of Moses what's going on here
then when they had assemble he said to
them okay this is him talking to
them brothers though had done nothing
against our people or the cousins or
ancestors okay so he's denying any
wrongdoing right but he clearly
committed wrong because circumcision
guys and we talked about this
circumcision is
how Jews know they are chosen people
there's a covenant between Abraham and
Yahweh God the Covenant
is the Abraham and his anwers will
circumcised themselves as a mark of
allegiance to Yahweh and return Yahweh
will give them the promised land okay so
circumcision is core to what it means to
be Jewish in fact it's the
main feature of being Jewish and here
Paul tells people oh you don't you don't
have to circumcise yourself so he's
clearly breaking the customs and laws of
their ancestors and he's saying nope I
didn't do anything wrong okay and again
these are Jewish leaders who know for a
fact Paul is guilty of this but the
people but the Jews don't speak up and
he and Paul continues yet I was arrested
in Jerusalem and over the Romans when
they had examined me the Romans want to
release me okay because there was no
reason for the death penalty in my case
the Romans want wanted to let me go but
the Jews insisted that I be killed so
it's the Romans who saved me
right but the Jews objected I was
compelled to appeal to the emperor Okay
so when the Jews wanted to kill me I
told the governor listen there's higher
authority than you and it's the emperor
and I want to go speak to the emperor
the governor had no choice but to send
guards soldiers to take me to Rome to be
Tried by the emperor and now okay this
is the most important
sentence even though I had no charge to
bring against my
nation okay what Paul is saying is this
Paul is saying when I I want I I could
go talk to the emperor but if I talk to
the emperor then it's because I accuse
my people the Jews of a crime against a
Roman
citizen you understand so what he's
doing it's very clever is he's making a
real threat to the Jewish leaders of
Rome if you mess with me I'm going to go
direct to the emperor and accuse you
guys of attacking Roman
citizen do you guys understand this you
see how radical this is this this speech
is radly different from the story before
in the
Bible so G Paul is accusing the Jews of
committing a
crime whereas before the Jews were
accusing Paul of committing a
crime and what Paul is saying is like
I'm right because access to the emperor
you don't okay and this is how the Bible
this is how the book ends okay the Acts
of the Apostles This Is How It Ends he
lived there two whole years at his
expense he's clearly very wealthy right
proclaiming the kingdom of God and
teaching about the Lord Jesus Christ
with all boldness and without hindrance
no one could touch this guy this is how
the story of Paul ends he's in Rome he
can do whatever he
wants and no one can touch him all right
so who is this guy how can he do
this he's a Jerusalem the mob's trying
to kill him the Roman soldiers come and
save him he and he goes back to Rome and
he tells the Jewish leaders there hey
guys don't mess with me and they leave
him alone and some even
convert who is this guy
Paul all right so that's a question
so any any questions so
far all right so
again there are a lot of questions in
the story of Paul that don't make any
sense okay the first thing that doesn't
make sense is like who is this guy right
he has all this power and money
and he can do whatever he wants and no
one can touch
him all right so that's the first big
question second big question
is um why does he
convert right his conversion story
doesn't make any sense we're like okay
well because he saw Jesus okay that's
fine but guess what
guys after Jesus talks to him Jesus sort
of disappears from the
story and you would think that
if Jesus was so important to
Paul Paul would quote from Jesus right
but he doesn't quote from Jesus Jesus
has a lot of message a lot of sayings
but Paul rarely quotes from
him okay but not only that we we already
said that the message of Jesus the
message of Paul are very
different Jesus believed the kingdom of
God was within us for for our generosity
for our Mercy we can achieve salvation
Paul taught everyone it's believe in
Jesus that will allow you to achieve
salvation and only believe in Jesus you
you can do as much good as you want but
if you don't believe in Jesus you'll be
damned to hell so all those Buddhists
all those Hindus all those zians who are
doing good in the world too bad they
will be burned in
hell and that goes against a lot of the
teachings of Jesus
okay so he did convert but he's not
spreading the Gospel of Jesus all right
all right
um another question then
is why is he focusing on
organization okay why is he focusing on
organization the heart of religion is
spiritual truth right but Paul doesn't
really care about that he cares about
the organization the church who's in
charge how many members we're attracting
how we can appeal to them more how how
do we resolve internal political
disputes within the church that's what
he cares about that's very
odd okay and then the last question then
is why
does why does he get in trouble with the
Jews and why do the Romans save him okay
so these are questions now let's first
go over for the Christian
explanation and the Christian
explanation
is Paul was part of divine
plan okay so Jesus brought truth into
the world right the truth of Jesus
that's what Jesus
teaches but it was Paul who created the
structure in the organization that
allowed Christianity to
spread okay
so um a analogy or or a comparison is
the story McDonald's
McDonald's you guys don't know
McDonald's right well guess what in
1950s McDonald's was one restaurant in
California it had amazing
hamburgers and um it really had the best
hamburgers and a man named Ray
visited this
restaurant and it was being run by
McDonald brothers that's why it's called
McDonald's okay and Ray Croc says to the
to the brothers you know what you guys
have an amazing restaurant let
me scale it out let me convince others
St McDonald's around America and the
world this is called the franchise model
OKAY the franchise
model the franchise model and so the
brother said yeah sure and what what R
Co did was he drove everywhere like Paul
and he had these meetings like Paul
where he convinced people of the
American dream like Paul Ray Croc said
to everyone if you open McDonald's you
will get rich and you will live the
American dream right Paul said to
everyone if you believe in Jesus you
will achieve
salvation and because Rick was such a
amazing salesperson McDonald's
eventually became uh the the largest
restaurant Empire in the world right
same thing with Paul because Paul was
just a convicting
salesman Christianity became the most
dominant religion in the world so this
is all part of God's plan okay it's very
similar to the story of McDonald's
here's the problem
guys Jesus was not selling
hamburgers in fact Jesus hated
hamburgers right the central message of
Jesus Is wealth is is wrong business is
wrong hierarchy is wrong what matters is
the spiritual truth in your
heart all right
so even though this is a
Christian belief that both are part of
the divine plan and
Paul was
doing Paul was basically Jesus's
business manager okay problem is Jesus
didn't want a business
manager and J believe that it was our
own individual responsibility to
discover our own truths through him okay
so what are some other explanations for
Paul okay all right so I mean the most
basic answer for people who hate Paul is
he was just an opportunist a
charlatan okay he saw business
opportunity everyone loved Jesus Jesus
was had gotone viral right he had gotone
viral and he and he was a meme now
around the world and so he wanted to
take advantage of that he wanted to
monetize that the problem with this
is he worked really hard man he Trav
around all he traveled all around the
Roman Empire to spread the message he
was fanatical about it okay and
opportunists are are are not fanatical
they're kind of lazy so I don't really
buy this idea that he was opportunist he
really believed in what he was
doing he was
driven by a sense of
mission okay and also guys remember if
he's a Roman citizen and his parents are
are Roman citizens then he's probably
wal for himself he doesn't really need
this
money also what's important for us to
understand is Paul comes from a very
well educated background he's very
wealthy he speaks Greek he writes Greek
beautifully he's classically educated
he doesn't want to deal with James the
just who is not well educated right he
doesn't he doesn't want to deal with
these people so why is he dealing with
these
people
right so I don't really buy this
explanation another
explanation is secret conspiracy the
idea here
is Paul and maybe many who supported him
hated the Roman Empire
and they believe Christianity would be a
weapon that would eventually destroy the
Roman Empire which is what happened
historically that's 3 34 years in the
future how could Paul know that and also
what does Paul have against the Roman
Empire really right he's he's
beneficiary of the Roman Empire he's
wealthy his parents are wealthy all
right so another explanation which by
the way I've never heard before but
which I do believe all right so take
this with a grain of
salt but I
believe he was a spy for the Roman
Empire all
right
okay there's a
spy okay so let let me explain the idea
here what is he doing and all
right so the Jews
have always been a problem for Empires
both the Greek Empire and the Roman
Empire why because the Greeks and the
Romans are pagans they celebrate pagan
gods but the Jews believe that their God
is the only God and every other God is
false and so they refused the authority
of the Empire this is led to many Wars
okay from 167 to 16 BCE there's
something called the meban revolt
against the saluan empire the last s
years killed a lot of people okay and
then there'll be the Romans and the Jews
will fight three major
Wars from 66 73 CE this is around the
time of Paul the first war will be
fought the Romans will burn the temple
down and ban all Jews from Jerusalem
and the Romans think through this
aggression the the Jews will be cowled
they'll be scared right no no no it
makes them even more Angry so that two
more Wars are fought from 115 to 117 and
then the third war will be from 132 to
136 okay so the Jews are
fanatical that's what G gives the Jews
power they're a poor province of the
Roman
Empire but they're fanatical and guess
what Romans respect fanaticism okay
remember
BC Hannibal
invades Italy and he
destroys all the Roman
armies uh again who who are against him
in the Battle of
Kai he has killed at least 20% of the
Roman adult male population and a third
of the Senate and at this point the
Romans should have surrendered and talk
peace right but the Romans are fanatical
they refuse to surrender and eventually
they're able to destroy carage okay
so now the Romans see the Jews who again
it's it's a poor small province in the
Roman Empire and they continue to
Rebel so this fanaticism of the Jews it
both scares and it alls the Romans
okay they they understand the Romans
above all understand how powerful fism
is fism is the Ultimate Weapon it cannot
be
defeated and because there's a diaspora
a Jewish diaspora can never be rooted
out okay you can destroy Jerusalem which
is what they did but they're Jews all
around the
world so you can never
destroy this fism
and because of the long history of the
Jews this phm only
grows through persecution and through
suffering okay so you have to somehow
destroy this fanaticism if you are to
win this war against the Jews and there
are three Central beliefs underlying
this Jewish fanaticism all right the
first is the idea of
Purity why is it that if the Jews are
God's chosen people they're always being
pushed around by these larger Empires
like the syrians the Babylonians the
Persians the Greeks and the Romans and
the answer is because we Jews have not
been pure enough we have not been loyal
enough to
Yahweh so it is only through Purity that
will allow us to eventually triumph over
over our
enemies
okay otherwise we will continue to be
bullied by
others second is the idea of persecution
complex the pers Christian complex the
entire world is against
us because we are God's chosen
people and therefore we must stand
United and stay
pure who the Jews really hated were the
Jews who assimilated like Paul right
they hated these people because they
were traitors to the nation of Israel
right second belief and then there's a
third belief which is the coming of the
Messiah don't worry about today okay
this pain this suffering this
persecution it's all part of the divine
plan it's testing us it is making us
strong event
the Messiah the anointed one will come
from heaven and lead us into a final
battle against all enemies the Roman
Empire and we will destroy them and then
we will
establish the nation of God the Kingdom
of Heaven on
Earth
okay and so these are the three major
beliefs that underpin Jewish fanm and it
makes the Jews almost Invincible because
it makes them fear
they're not afraid to die dying is part
of divine plan suffering is all part of
the process of achieving the Kingdom of
Heaven on Earth it's the responsibility
to die for the faith okay all right so
now that that we understand this Jewish
fanm we can
Now understand why Paul is doing what
he's doing right think about this Purity
means absolute obedience to the law of
Moses right but what Paul's saying is no
guys
circumcision circumcision is we don't we
don't have to enforce circumcision
because we want more non-jews into our
religion okay why circumcision such a
big deal well because circumcision is
basically what um separates the Jews
into a different group of people in in
any Community why because in most cities
there's a place called
gymnasium gymnasium is really the heart
and center of life in the community it's
it's it's where PE where men go to do
Sports and Athletics like wrestle and
run okay the female of genium is
everyone goes in
naked right and why is this a problem
because if you're
Jewish people know right away You're
Jewish therefore it's hard for you to go
into gymnasium because you're being
ridiculed by the Greeks therefore
there's no way for the Jews to
associate with the Greeks and other
people okay does that make sense that's
why circumcision is so important once
you out once you say to the Jewish
people you don't need to be circumcised
you just have to have faith in Jesus
it's easier for them to assimilate into
the larger culture around them
right pers persecution complex Jews are
being persecuted why because they're not
Roman
citizens right let's go back to the
story of Jesus why did he get persecuted
why did he die because he was not a
Roman citizen if he were a Roman citizen
then P pilate would have protected him
from the Jews who wanted to kill him
just like how the Roman soldiers
protected Paul from those Jews wanted to
kill
him so guys
focus on being a Roman citizen and you
can believe anything you want you will
no longer be persecuted you'll be part
of the Roman Empire right and the last
thing is the coming of the Messiah right
Jews believe the Messiah is going to
come and lead them into final Victory
against all their enemies especially the
Roman Empire but what Paul is saying is
this that Mah has already come he's
Jesus and Jesus taught a message of
Eternal
salvation Eternal salvation to recognize
The Evil Within you and to become a
better
person so if you are if you want to be
saved you must believe that we are born
evil and Jesus has come to cleanse us of
our
Evil Jesus was a prophet of Peace he had
nothing against the Roman Empire he he
was fighting against evil in the
world
okay so if these three things are true
then fism will be
destroyed now obviously you're a fanatic
you don't believe any of this crap okay
but Paul's message was not for fanatical
Jews they were still a minority his
message were for diaspora Jews like him
who were stuck between the Roman Empire
and the Jewish faith right they were
part of the Jewish
diaspora maybe the fathers were Greek
and the mothers were Jewish okay and
these are a lot of people so Paul's
message was for these people you can
still be Jewish if you believe in
Jesus and once you believe in Jesus then
you can now
assimilate into the Roman
Empire and that's will free you to
believe whatever you
want
okay so this is
Paul's
Mission now then the question then is
why is Paul doing this why would Paul do
this and I think the answer is this I
don't want to say Paul is opportunist or
he's evil I believe he was also a
believer in his mission his mission was
what to save his
people if you want to continue to live
within the Roman Empire you have to
adapt yourself you have to make
compromises you can't wait for the
Messiah to come save you you have to
save yourself by adapting to the Roman
Empire and look there are lots of
advantages to the Roman
Empire you can become very happy and
prosperous if you play by the rules of
the Roman Empire like he did okay so in
many ways what's odd about Paul is he
teaches us that Jesus is a messiah but
in his heart and you can tell by his
writings he himself believes he's really
the Messiah who has come to save his
people and that's why he's so fanatical
about building the Church of
Christianity the church that will
eventually become Christianity okay
again at this point in history they're
not Christians they're still Jews
okay but there will be a lot of
consequences because Paul is doing this
he rally changes the meaning of faith
and religion all
right because again the story of Jesus
doesn't really make any sense and his
story doesn't make any sense either okay
he's lying he's lying about who he
is so he creates A New
Concept and he radically changes the
concept of Faith
okay before faith is what you experience
now Faith is something that you must
believe right he introduces the idea of
Miracles
now if something can't can be explain
it's because it's a
Miracle all right and this is a new idea
that didn't really didn't exist before
and the use of Miracles is to
explain the contradictions or the
inconsistencies in the story of the
Bible
okay so that's one major uh revolution
of Paul's teachings another
is the idea of
tradition tradition is more important
than the Bible okay so the stories
interpretation of the Bible is now more
important than the Bible itself and the
Paul's Church will eventually become the
Catholic church and one thing about the
Catholic church is you are not allowed
to read the Bible the Bible is sacred
it's forbidden only priests are allowed
to read the Bible because the fear is if
you read the Bible you might
misinterpret the word of God okay you
don't have the spiritual power in order
to fully interpret the Bible
properly
okay all right okay so there are lots of
major changes to the idea of religion
because of Paul's work all right so that
is my central argument about Paul are
there any
questions about any of
this yes
um
okay uh you you have a question about
Islam can can we can we save Islam for
later on okay yeah so but I'll answer
Islam okay that'll be like next week
okay
um okay that's a great question like who
wrote The Acts of Apostles all right so
um we don't know who rol The Acts of the
Apostles okay but this this is what we
do
know whoever wrote The Acts of the
Apostles was written by the guy who
wrote Luke okay the Gospel of Luke which
is one of the four main gospels of the
Bible why because um the ACT Apostles is
is the continuation of the story of
Jesus found in Luke okay so if wrote
Luke is also a person who wrote Acts of
the Apostles
the first thing we know second thing
that we know
is the the Luke gospel was written maybe
between 80 and 90 CE okay so this this
about 50 to 60 years after the death of
Jesus okay um and Paul might still be
alive at this time what we also know is
this act of Apostles is very Pro
Paul
okay so what's important to understand
is the story I'm telling you is a story
that comes from individuals who are
trying to promote a positive picture of
Paul and why are they doing that because
at this point in history there are a lot
of people especially Jews who hate Paul
they feel that Paul has corrupted their
religion especially the teachings of
Jesus and and I I I believe it at this
point in history because of the way that
Paul behaves it's an Open Secret that
he's working very closely with the Roman
Empire he's either
collaborator or he's a spy okay and
that's why they had to write the Acts of
the Apostles to sort of like apologize
or to clean up the image of Paul and
again we've seen this throughout history
right remember the Bible started out as
an apology for King
David so this is extremely sympathetic
towards Paul and again what what it's
shown you is that through a close
reading you can see how problematic
problematic it is
all
right okay so does it answer your
question all right any more
questions okay all right great
so let's talk about uh next class okay
next
class we will talk about uh monotheism
the coming of
uh
monotheism okay because this is a
revolution in human history and human
thought all right so um there are many
scholars who believe that monotheism
means believe in one God what I will
show you next class is um
monotheism it is is it's a radical
reconception of
reality okay and and that and that's
what I I will teach you next class right